en el vídeo anterior tratamos de
adivinar cuál era la solución para
nuestra ecuación diferencial y llegamos
a una exponencial como respuesta y
conforme hicimos el análisis
desarrollamos la ecuación característica
y terminamos con una respuesta compleja
para uno de los parámetros ajustables
que es la frecuencia natural de nuestro
circuito esta es la forma de nuestra
solución propuesta y luce complicada
pero no se preocupen vamos a simplificar
la muy pronto tenemos dos soluciones
para ese s1 y s2 que pusimos como más o
menos j
omega 0 y tenemos otros parámetros
ajustables de amplitud que tenemos que
encontrar en este vídeo vamos a seguir
resolviendo nuestra ecuación diferencial
y algo que vamos a hacer aquí es algo
muy importante en la electrónica y en
general también vamos a usar la fórmula
de oyler que de hecho son dos fórmulas
vamos a usar estas fórmulas para saber
qué hacer con estos términos
exponenciales complejos si ustedes
buscan este término en khan academy se
encontrarán una explicación de dónde
vienen estas expresiones pero aquí
solamente las vamos a enunciar y la
fórmula de hoy leer es el elevado a la
jota por equis cualquier cosa aquí
arriba es igual al coseno de x más jota
seno de x
esta es una de las fórmulas la otra
fórmula nos dice que a la menos jx es
igual a coseno de x menos j por seno de
x estas no son útiles porque tienen esta
función con la unidad compleja dentro de
ellas y si vemos este lado tenemos un
número complejo digamos que normal el
coseno de x es un número que se
encuentra entre más y menos uno seno de
x es un número que se encuentra entre
más y menos uno y es un número complejo
normal así que esto nos puede ayudar a
simplificar nos la vida conforme
resolvemos esto así que estas son
fórmulas muy importantes y las vamos a
usar para resolver nuestro circuito lc
vamos a reescribir nuestras
exponenciales usando la fórmula de hoy
leer se va a hacer un poco grande pero
verán que pronto va a hacerse más
pequeño
es igual a cada uno por el ala más j
omega 0 t así que usemos esta fórmula de
acá por el coseno x es omega 0 por t más
j por seno de omega 0 t ya transformamos
nuestro primer término ahora vamos a
hacer lo mismo con el segundo término y
para éste vamos a usar la segunda
fórmula de hoy leer más k 2 por ahora
tenemos el negativo en el exponente por
coseno de omega 0 t - j por el seno de
omega 0 t aquí ya tenemos extendida
todas nuestra solución vamos a reducir
la vamos a poner juntos todos los
términos de coseno y haremos lo mismo
con todos los términos de seno y es
igual coseno de omega 0 t y el coche no
está x cada uno más k 2 a esto le
sumamos tenemos jota seno y j seno
así que lo vamos a escribir aquí este es
el omega 0 t por aquí ponemos la j y va
a estar x que pues tenemos aquí acá 1 y
ahora tenemos este signo negativo que
hace que tengamos una menos que 2 así
que tenemos que la corriente es igual a
un número que multiplica a coseno de
omega 0 t más j que multiplica a otro
número por este seno estas son dos
constantes arbitrarias así que vamos a
inventar otra constante que le vamos a
llamar a 1 aún no es igual a cada uno
más caros y ésta será a 2 que va a ser
igual aquí incluyo a la j k 1 - k 2 y
ahora podemos reescribir todo esto como
como
y igual a 1 coseno omega 0 t más a 2
seno omega 0 t de aquí en adelante vamos
a trabajar con estas as y si en algún
momento queremos saber qué significan
regresaremos a estas ecuaciones de acá
una vez que yo encuentre los valores d
podremos encontrar los valores de ambas
casas como podemos encontrar a1 y a2
para hacer esto vamos a necesitar las
condiciones iniciales
recordemos que en nuestro circuito
original
teníamos una q aquí lo que indica que
aquí también tenemos de 0 y dijimos que
la corriente que pasa por aquí comenzaba
en 0 estas son nuestras condiciones
iniciales de cuando el tiempo es igual a
0 es igual a b 0 y la corriente cuando
el tiempo es igual a 0 es igual también
a 0 usaremos estos valores para
encontrar a a1 y a2 esto lo haremos en
el siguiente vídeo mientras seguimos
encontrando la deducción de esta
respuesta natural